if you love my body just rush the border
new video shows chaos at the southern
border over ten thousand migrants
cramming themselves under a bridge in
del rio texas and officials say ten
thousand more immigrants are on their
way to join them the massive makeshift
shelter highlighting just how bad the
problem is are on bill mollusian showing
earlier how migrants can easily cross a
dam and make their way into texas with
no resistance now keep in mind the white
house refuses to say that what we are
all seeing is a crisis they won't call
it a crisis republicans are furious with
the president and the fact that he's
allowing this to happen watch
it is the most horrific thing i've ever
seen it is packed in as a mass of
humanity when it comes to illegal
immigration you just can't trust the
biden administration
it would be like trusting harvey
weinstein with your daughter he is
failing and he is willfully disregarding
his duty to enforce the laws of the
united states this is not authorized by
the state of texas it's not
welcomed by the state of texas or any
other republican state that i know and
they're not invited
so emily this has become such a crisis
and it's only been recently that del rio
has become such a magnet and uh they're
saying it's because the president has
refused to fly these mostly haitian
immigrants back to
haiti so
what is going on here
tragedy upon tragedy compounded by an
inept administration that refuses to
acknowledge that this crisis is even
present and for an administration that
claims to prioritize covet over
everything you know the vaccination rate
in haiti is 0.1
8 000 of those migrants under that
bridge are from haiti as you pointed out
we know that for example in mcallen
texas there were there was a 15 coveted
positive rate in the 7 000 migrants that
have been released into that town in
recent months however remember new york
city public schools shut down at three
percent so which is it what is the
priority of this administration now i
know that they're folding into this
humongous bill that with our tax dollars
will fund amnesty for all but in the
interim it's a complete humanitarian
crisis these people have no adequate
shelter what looks like a party is an
absolute cesspool they are standing in
their own feces there's no running water
that's clean there's no potable water
there's no food sources and instead of
being put back to a safe place where
they're from
they're just being left there in squalor
with an administration and a mainstream
media that turns its head and they can't
turn their head right now because fox
has been
flying a drone over the area just to
just to capture the footage so people
can see exactly what's going on and the
number of desperate haitians south
americans mexicans who are trying to get
into this country but bill mollusion has
been reporting that there's a temporary
temporary flight restriction for two
weeks so we won't even be able to see
these pictures and and you have three
kids that you know of uh you do have a
baby and so when babies put their hands
over their eyes they think that no one
can see them so the bite administration
uh wants to remove the fox news drone so
no one can see how bad it's really
gotten in del rio that's the pattern
that we've seen he creates a crisis then
tries to cover it up and then lie about
it first they wouldn't let the media in
to these camps where they had the kids
in cages then they hid the kids flew
them all over the country and now
they're saying fox can't fly our drone
overhead to captain and they did they
did lift the ban a few hours ago because
there was a lot of pushback when it was
a very obviously politically motivated
ban right and so that's what they do and
then they lie and they say everything's
fine it's not a crisis actually it's
trump's fault and which one is it but
here's why the media doesn't cover it i
think fox is the only one with a drone
one of the main reasons is because a lot
of people that work out in new york and
dc they don't even see texas as part of
the country this is this silly red state
way down south maybe they'll go to
austin to south by southwest they'll get
a kick out of the music in the bar and
then they'll fly right back and say i've
been to texas they don't go to
brownsville they don't go to mcallen or
laredo they don't understand if you have
neither does vice president harris
neither does she right so
if you have 10 000 haitians
or
random guys from nicaragua or mexico
just lined up pouring into a small town
a ranching town families that have kids
in school and small businesses you're
just going to overwhelm that town the
town can't handle that kind of influx of
random people like that on vax no
documents no education no english you're
going to pour across the border into a
small town like that these people are
crying out for help and the media just
doesn't care because they're not
affected by it it's a 27 hour drive from
texas to new york it might as well be
australia
that's a much longer drive with no
bridge harder to drive to australia good
point jesse uh so how do the democrats
make a political win out of this because
you have republicans and democrats in a
state that's trying to go from purplish
to blue and you have
democrat lawmakers who see what's
happening and see how the towns and
their constituents to jesse's point are
completely overrun and this is something
that republicans are going to make hay
with next year in the midterms oh i
think that's a good i think that's a
good question and a valid question uh
kennedy and i think the way to start is
by telling the story of those haitians
at that border and here's what we know
we know this that most of the haitians
that are at that border would qualify
for temporary protective status under
american law under international law
many of those people have been through
two earthquakes two hurricanes many of
them left the country of haiti they got
on ships and went to brazil they then
walked on foot from brazil to america's
southern border a journey that takes
almost 15 months right and as they're on
the southern border they are waiting to
qualify for asylum many of them can
qualify for asylum because of a title 52
which is a program that says because of
health restrictions you cannot cross
that border because of america's clogged
immigration courts they are not seeing
an immigration judge so this is a story
about delays in the immigration courts
an unmodernized immigration court system
has caused many of these folks that
would qualify for temporary protective
status to be as as as you just said
emily to be in a situation where there's
a humanitarian crisis on the southern
border by people that will qualify for
humanitarian
in the united states we are a giving
country right that's why we have lady
liberty a couple miles from here these
individuals who we who is who we should
be giving so they are prioritized no no
it's not prioritizing no no it's not
about prioritizing them over that these
are folks who are
that's the argument that you're making
right now i'm saying
i mean whatever the administration is
there's an a fixed number of people very
very very true right but i'm saying
there's already laws and there's already
a law in place on the books for them to
qualify temporary protective status they
would qualify for that problem is many
of them aren't seeing an immigration
judge because the courts are just so
overrun they're so clogged that it might
be two or three years before they even
the difference the difference richard is
you have americans still stranded in
afghanistan who biden has abandoned what
you're mixing up with
thousands of nations you're mixing up
with an orange don't qualify for
immigration
versus
overseas right now make them a price
don't verify the manifest we certainly
can't verify 10 000 people a day who are
coming into a small town greg yeah it is
interesting so the government actually
tries to temporarily take down the
drones in the previous administration
they would have invited the press down
to see everything i guess biden only
approves of drones if they're killing
people uh if this coverage this uh bill
moluson coverage
this amazing
you know uh uh footage we're on any
other network let's say nbc it would win
emmys because the visuals have the power
of creating a real true narrative uh
that richard should applaud because it
would tell the story that he would want
to hear these visuals are striking uh
they're forcing the mainstream media to
actually maybe you know get off their
butts these are images that honestly can
make a difference uh but it tells you
why nothing changes it's because the
media are the gatekeepers uh uh the left
are the media gatekeepers for the media
if there's this one small like trickle
of injustice anywhere under a republican
the media will amplify it right but you
could have months
of this we've had we've had months of
this
a lot of it suffering a lot of it
unmitigated suffering and it takes fox
and fox's visuals and build mallution
to force the media into a corner to do
this when a democrat's in power you
actually have to shame them to actually
do their jobs um but this is why we
often can't do anything about it because
the monopoly the monopoly of thought in
the media which is aligned with the with
uh democrats makes this kind of coverage
so rare and i i don't know how they go
forward when now they can see this this
is award-winning stuff
nbc gave this four seconds coverage of
this issue in mainstream media besides
us has declined 94
while the surge itself of these people
of these humans has increased by over
300 percent to your point
but they know they're suffering they
just don't want to tell the story if
they if they did maybe you could
alleviate it